hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play to nippers Lake okay
some people have called into question my
manliness at this game to put Sam the
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah I know
no no okay I went in that hole I think
I'm done here right I got what I needed
I got a code to some door something else
when there's nothing left of darkness a
man can only can do nothing but water
what's to become of his soul yeah all
right so to prove that a big manly man
I'm gonna be scared at all
uh-uh I'm so brave so grateful oozes hey
did that it was a lock on there was
happy with what what was okay whatever I
think that was the door that I put there
ah yes indeed chapter 5 the truth the
truth Nuala not scared haha see you up
there
I'll see you yeah yeah yeah
oh that's a lovely lovely painting mmm
actually it that I think it did
just double-checking okay now we go now
we ride and now I'm going to look up
there
one second hello hi oh come on I gonna
be like that huh
hi yeah get out of here that's gonna
thought oh oh oh
yeah what
whoo
okay
hey oh man oh man God oh and a nightclub
yeah my closet yeah
suddenly brave not scared even a little
bit
oh yeah huh hmm chair ba so strong
I see you back there ah I saw that okay
okay
this looks like the perfect place for a
trap yeah
bugger off okay all right I'm flying
it's obviously nothing here no big scary
monsters not scary anyway so I thought
cheer what's with all these 100 nights I
don't like them I don't like a rednecks
they're just big mannequins oh hello
there's something behind the door I need
it break the door somehow since its
hinges have rusted okay
you failed English but that's okay I
think you're from another country land
oh it's just a big circle
there's another door right not what what
do I do this me I've got a great big
piece of meat and nothing to do with it
if I go back I thought there was another
door there yeah oh oh two points yeah
okay
it's gone fireplace the corners nothing
in there looking for like a crowbar
something that's obviously what I need
maybe upstairs I missed it somehow I
don't know I guess I could go out again
probably on the courtyard there's
something else I'm gonna go check I mean
there was a lot of courtyard that I
didn't explore oh let me go take a look
around and when you gaze into the abyss
the abyss gazes also into maybe there
wasn't oh yeah see there's another door
over here okay
hello budge yeah I locked that I found
him something oops go around I found you
large oil push or I guess I might have
been here bollocks
Luger there's a door up there but I'm
thinking get to it I think a lot of
things are tricky here that's where
these various okay I'm assuming that
wait no no hear something throw my meat
at it if you know what I mean okay
enough of that enough of that hidden
stuff back in I guess light thinks it
travels faster than anything but it's
wrong my offensive truffles he finds the
darkest is all we got their first center
is waiting for it blah blah blah blah a
fourth time
I'm pretty sure upstairs somewhere I
must have missed maybe down here in the
fire here
some sort of Fire poker rub our don't
push me table op mushi right back oh no
I came back all the Knights have their
heads again oh uh don't
hmm hello box I know I've already
checked all the drawers must be
something in here up here something I
missed something
American bash it open with the leg
immune system handle role of chair I'll
try that yeah I didn't try my old recipe
it's bro rock at it throw a rug is
closed you never know it was something
here no go mmm box ah oh yeah no crowbar
it's box 200 still heavy oh okay now
finally bunk which is like practically
off already
what with one potato two potato five day
hmm something else fine here no hmm yeah
I see it
yeah sure
I don't see like some sort of staircase
or something
looks like it try the hunka me here ah
oh you gotta begin
ah you're funny
where is he coming from I need to hide
that's Delia I need to get in the closet
or something
hey buddy enjoy my meat is tender and
delicious okay go you know who you know
who's carrying the V Tommy the whole
time I couldn't I am NOT you're not here
where are you who are you you don't even
understand it well no not this is it
just patrolling
mother [ __ ] come here just come here
boom
that's right yes get that me why did I
walk right in oh whatever
right I saw some stairs so behind the
stairs seems likely oh wow
for once there is not for once in this
story in most of the stories goodbye oh
there's the room of nightmares
as like my worst fear in that room oh no
no I'm going back no I got saved I'll
save this for next time
Oh
tough I'm tough mmm mmm hmm hmm hmm mm
hmm
no no nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope no no no no no safe safe safe
Jim dad again keep him safe okay all
right I think I'm just a bad time yeah
you know and say it's luck hmm anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you all so much for
watching and remember I'm brave hey
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next one
hi